Now, not every fraction is so easy.
Some go on forever.
For example, let's say we want to
convert one-third to a decimal.
Let's try doing the same
method we did before.
So this is the same
thing as 1 divided by 3.
And again for precision,
we'll add a few trailing 0s here,
and we'll add a decimal
point right here.
So how many times does 3 go into 1?
0, and how many times does 3 go into 10?
That'd be 3.
3 times 3 is 9.
Let's do our subtraction, and we get 1.
We'll bring our 0 down.
And now how many times
does 3 go into 10 here?
Once again, it'll go in 3 times.
And we get 9, we do our subtraction,
and what do you know?
We get 1 again.
Bring down our 0 and same as before,
3 goes into 10 3 times,
and it looks like
there's a pattern here.
It looks like we could just
keep going on forever and
we would just keep adding more 3s.
And in fact, that's true.
This is called a repeating decimal.
It's called a repeating decimal
because the 3 here repeats on forever.
So we can write this a couple of ways.
The fraction one-third is equivalent
to 0.3 with a bar over it.
The bar over the top here means
that the 3s go on forever.
But because there's a bar,
we don't have to keep writing the 3s.
Sometimes this is also written
as 0.33 with a bar over it.
It's the same thing.
We could also use rounding, and if we
decide to round to two decimal places,
that means we look at these two 3s,
and we move over to the right one.
And because this is less than 5,
we can just ignore it.
So I will use this symbol which
means about equal to 0.33.
We rounded off all the 3s
after the first two decimals.
We can write one-third is
approximately equal to 0.33.
Now can you tell me what is
one-seventh as a decimal?
Round your answer to two decimal
places and enter it here.